good evening members and offices of the
council the members of the press and
public I welcome you to this annual
meeting of the council if the fire alarm
is activated please vacate the officers
via the stairs I have through the
security doors to my right or opposite
the lifts in the fray please do not use
the lifts please assemble in holy square
on the green officers will assist you
and advise when it is deemed safe to
return to the chamber the Proceedings of
this meeting will be recorded and
subsequently broadcast on the internet I
would advise that the filming takes
place anyone in attendance in the public
areas may have that image captured I
urge anyone filming proceedings to avoid
filming members of the public
particularly if there are children
present
does anyone intend filming the meeting
any members of the public who objects to
the possibility of being filmed may wish
to take this opportunity to leave the
meeting any filming or recording will
not be permitted for any item of
business where exempt or confidential
information is considered following the
exclusion of the press and public from
the meeting would everyone present
please ensure that their mobile phones
are turned to silent and that they are
not used to make or receive phone calls
in the chamber while this meeting is in
progress apologies for absence apologies
have been received from councillors
current and Venables are there any other
apologies councillor prune
agenda item number two is election of
chairman the first item of business is
to elect the chairman of the Council for
the ensuing year
are there any nominations councilor
Beauford yeah Thank You chair yes I'd
like to nominate councillor David
Saunders David's been a TVC councillor
for seven years and Broadstairs and sim
Peters Town Council for is slightly
longer I believe it's been a past mayor
of Broadstairs and sim Peters two years
running for the last three years he's
been a superb chair of overview and
scrutiny and actually steered that panel
through some fairly choppy waters at
times a couple of memorable public
meetings here where his patience and
good humor were tested to the limit more
importantly is a chant an athletic
supporter what more could you what what
more could you want
honestly that the chair is the public
face of TDC and we couldn't have a
better ambassador than David Saunders
and I'm delighted to propose him as
chair of the year in schooi thank you is
there a second
thank you very much I'd like to second
that nomination thank you
are there any other nominations
all right as there are no other
candidates I declare that councillor
Saunders has been elected chairman of
Senate District Council for the ensuing
year I would just like to say a word
words as outgoing chairman first of all
I would like to thank Madeleine homer
and all the senior officers who have
reluctantly kept me on the straight and
narrow but without them you cannot
function only it is very a very
fulfilling task to do I would like to
thank council hunt astonish maxing and
councillor Sarah Larkins for being my
escorts I would like to thank councilor
Robin Edwards for his stalwart support
has been my advice chairman and last but
not least I would like to thank Charlie
she is a gem she gets you wherever
you've got to go there's always a smile
on her face and she is a really really
lovely person Thank You charlie for a
most enjoyable year please now be
upstanding while the platform party
retires for a few minutes in order for
the new chairman to be invested with the
train and badge of office
it's the first time I've seen the
scripts of this evening so I'll do my
best
no ad-libbing tonight members I call
upon the monitoring officer Thank You
chairman I'm about right counsel
Saunders as a chairman for 2018-19
to make the declaration of acceptance of
office
i david saunders having been elected to
the office of chairman of Thanet
district council declare that i take the
that office upon myself and will duly
and faithfully fulfill the duties of it
according to the best of my judgment and
ability
having done that my next duty is to
appoint my escort and I therefore have
had very little discussion prior to this
meeting but I'd like to elect my wife
councillor Maeve Saunders thumbs up so
we're on the right Road thank you very
much
[Applause]
and we move on to agenda item 3 which is
the election of a vice chairman
are there any nominations council Piper
Thank You chair I'd like to nominate
councillor Gary Taylor it's a real
pleasure to put his name forward for
this post he is the visible face of
counselors in the Dane Valley area of
people are used to seeing him around and
I think he would do a splendid job
assisting you on the top table Thank You
chair
is there a seconder yes I'm more than
happy to second that are there any other
nominations as there are no other
nominate nominations for candidates I
declare that councillor Gary Taylor is
elected vice chairman of Fannett Council
for the ensuring year thank you
thank you I call upon the monitoring
officer I invite counselor Gary Taylor
as a vice chairman for 2018-19
to make the declaration of acceptance of
office
i gary taylor have been having been
elected to the office of vice chairman
or fanic district council declare that i
take office upon myself and will duly
and faithfully for for the duties of its
according to the best of my judgment and
ability that's a point my escort is my
wife Kelly Taylor thank you if I can
congratulate councilor Taylor I'm sure
you'll do a very good supporting role
and as has already been mentioned once
the football season comes along he may
well have to fulfill that role on
occasion for me so we move on to the
formal agenda now and that's agenda item
4 which is minutes of the previous
meeting
I move that the minutes of the previous
council meeting held on the 12th of
April 2018 be approved with the vice
chairman please second I think a second
there do members agree that I sign the
minutes as a true record thank you
agenda item 5 these declarations of
interests are there any declarations of
interest councillor campbell only a
general declaration of interest in
agenda item 11 members allowance scheme
think that's taken as read monitor
officer will make comment thank you
cheering yes it's already a general
dispensation in place for all members in
terms of their payment allowances thank
you agenda item 6 is announcements and
it is with regret that I have to
announce that councillor Allen house has
passed away
I'm sure the council will join me in
expressing sympathy to councilor Hayes's
family could all members therefore
please stand for a minute silence as in
mark a respect for the late councillor
house
thank you
does any member wish to say a few words
counsel Piper Thank You chair
they have indeed been a great deal of
sadness expressed by many people today
and it is in that spirit of sadness that
we learned of the death of our friend
councillor Alan house Alan joined this
group in January because he has always
been fiercely independent wanting to
serve his community and to one of
pledges that he made
Alan served as vice chairman of this
council for two years and what we
learned from that among other things was
that he was perfectly capable of
behaving in a manner befitting the
occasion he knew too how to cut to the
crux of the matter without any props and
teasin he had a passion for speaking his
mind and telling the truth as he saw it
which certainly rippled the waters on
more than one occasion such characters
are people who make life a little more
interesting for the rest of us he has
always been a feisty character even back
in the day when he was a senior London
black cab operator I'm told that he once
bought large parts of London to a
standstill
when organizing a protest to protect his
colleagues Alan was immensely proud of
his association with the Freemasons and
tried to live according to his faith
contributors to social media posts on
birching to pages today have spoken with
genuine appreciation for his forthright
honesty it may be that from time to time
there's a temptation for some of us and
I include myself to get a little too
carried away with our own sense of
importance in this place but Alan never
forgot that it was ordinary local people
who put him here and he was determined
to serve them and not himself we send
our deepest sympathies to Alan's wife
during his daughter's Claire and Jan and
his beloved grandchildren Morgan
Denham Alice and Lauren thank you Jeff
Thank You councillor Piper councillor
Wells Thank You chairman yes Alan the
course served as a Yuka cancer from May
2015 until Johnny
this year and for two years as the vice
chairman of this council has already
been said I suppose having been quite
shocked initially by the news this
morning I upon reflection I think it's
one of three things always remember very
clearly about Alan which were stick in
my mind I think from the day I met him
until a long time hence the first was
his enormous pride in being a member
representing Burlington I mean you
couldn't fill a room with people who
would not think of him as being proud
and wanting to do what the best he could
for the village itself on each and every
occasion the second I think would be his
usual very swift condemnation of why
birch and she should be protective
against dfl which is almost immediately
followed by the mission that he was
himself a DFL but obviously in his mind
of a different type and sort and and
perhaps for those year on the planning
committee a lot remember Alan for having
his own slightly independent to bikini
interpretation of planning legislation
and never quite understanding why
everybody else to concede his way may he
rest in peace
and certainly our sympathy goes to his
his wife and family as well thank you
Thank You councillor wells gender items
7 responsibility for functions executive
I call upon the leader yes thank you
chairman ma be the first to congratulate
you and councillor tiger on your
appointments I gather at this stage I
have to announce who my portfolio
holders are and that's corporate
governance and coastal development
councillor Savage operational services
counts the Taylor Smith financial
services counselor Gregory Housing a
safer neighborhoods counts the game and
everything that nobody else wants me
thank you
Thank You councillor favored I now call
upon counselor Reverend Piper to name me
his opposition spokes people
councillor Python thank you Jeff nobody
wants me very much either so I'll shadow
councillor Beauford our opposition
spokesperson
and deputy leader of this group is
counselor Edward J Jones corporate
governance coastal development is
Catholic jewelry zeki operational
services counselor suzanne brim housing
and safer neighborhoods councillor
Edward J Jones financial services and
estates councillor Trevor Xiang Thank
You councillor purple
I call upon councillor Wells to name his
opposition spokespersons yes thank you
I'll lift the piece of paper behind so I
might just get this wrong but counselor
John town into the corporate and is
States Council and in Fairbrass to be
deputy leader and housing etc councillor
hunt establish merging to shadow
councillor savage councillor direct crow
brown to shadow council all right Savage
yeah what time I can miss of this and
nobody really what's the bits are going
to do which is demon counselor Beaufort
but I will put that up in a list surely
thanks for councilors asked to note the
cabinet portfolios cabinet portfolio
holders opposition spokespeople
portfolios operational accountabilities
and exactly if delegated functions this
item is for noting only and cannot be
voted upon thank you
a general item 8 appointment of
independent members of the standard
committee I move that the council
approved the appointment of dr. Sexton
as an independent member of the
Standards Committee until the 2019
annual council meeting with the vice
chairman please second for second area
thank you do members agree thank you I
move that the council approved the
appointment of mrs. bacon as an
independent member of the Standards
Committee until the 2019 annual council
meeting with the vice chairman please
second second that year do members agree
Thank You general item 9
constitution of committees political
balance appointments to committees
panels and boards would members please
refer to the supplementary agenda item
number one and the members notes with
members please note that the report does
not reflect the recent passing of
councilor house the options proposed in
the report will be an interim
arrangement pending the recalculation of
proportionality for consideration at the
council meeting on the 12th of July
number and size of committees I move
that the number of committees and the
number of members to serve on those
committees as shown in table 1 of the
report be adopted with the vice chairman
please second a second that chair do
members agree thank you political
proportionality I call upon the leader
to make a proposal in respect to the
options as outlined in the report
yeah thank you chairman unlike council
of worlds who is unprepared option 1
I've written down here thank you
is there a seconder aisle that Mister
cheering thank you does any member wish
to a propose an alternative option it
was just one option proposed do members
agree thank you
this committee Standards Committee I
move that the council agrees to waive
proportionality for the standards
committee and to apply the approximate
proportionality as set out in table 4 of
the report would the vice chairman
please second second Tim do members
agree thank you joint transportation
board I move that council agrees the
proportionality between groups for the
Thanet district council seats on the
joint transportation board set out in
table 45 of the report would the vice
chairman please second second that chair
do members agree thank you East Kent
joint Arrangements committee I move that
council agrees the joint Arrangements
committee as set out in table six of the
report with the vice chairman please
second second that yet members agree
thank you nomination of members to serve
on committees the group leaders have
advised of their nominations to the
committee's which have been set out in
the members notes does any group leader
wish to make any changes council be
third yes thank you chairman I'm very
conscious that I took a lot of mixed
time yesterday trying to make this as
smooth as silk unfortunately I've got a
couple of things wrong so I would like
to add so the planning committee
councillor Evans on governance and audit
I would like to remove counts the game
and counts of Gregory and add councillor
messenger and counts the bambridge and
on joint transportation remove
councillor Dawson counts the game for
there as KCC members anyway and add
councillors Rogers and Parsons
thank you subject to those minor
revisions with the vice-chairman please
sorry let's add to stand this councillor
Dawson thank you any other changes in
that case once my friend on my right
let's finish writing I will ask the vice
chairman - please second based of course
with those revisions second next year
thank you do members agree thank you
elections of Chairman and vice chairman
of committees panels and boards for the
2000 1890 municipal year I move that the
council agrees the election with those
nominations for chairman and vice
chairman of committees as shown in the
members notes would the vice chairman
please second second that year do
members agree thank you Standards
Committee and constitutional review
working party I move that dr. jonathan
sexton be appointed chairman of the
standards committee and the
constitutional review working party for
the 2018-19
municipal year and that mrs. Janet bacon
be appointed vice chairman of the
Standards Committee and constitutional
review working party for the 2018-19
municipal year with the vice chairman
please second second a chair do members
agree thank you agenda item 10
presentation on outside bodies with
members please refer to the members note
I call upon the leader to propose the
lists of non-executive and make
nominations to those non-executive
outside bodies yes thank you chairman
I'd like to propose that the list as
appears in members notes and the
nominations thereon and I would also ask
members again to look at the
of what is where we currently don't have
representatives and if anybody is
prepared to volunteers Garner's would
they contact me fairly same place thank
you go ah councillor Campbell yeah Thank
You Jerry got a nomination it's I'd like
to suggest that the representatives on
these outside bodies make some report at
some stage throughout the year so he'd
know exactly what's going on on these
outside bodies at the moment he's mute
we hear nothing I don't want them to
stand out individually and spend hours
and hours talking perhaps more written
report that could be sent around or an
email perhaps you in the loop even when
four members of what's going on on the
outside bullies Thank You councillor
stirred Campbell I think that's an
excellent suggestion and we have raised
it at scrutiny in the past do I have a
seconder to that was the second it
wasn't do members agree thank you
and agenda item 11 is members allowance
scheme 2018-19
would members please note there is a
typographical error in recommendation
number one of the report the
recommendation should read to amend the
names of the following SR A's group
leader of largest opposition group to be
known as opposition leader of a group
with ten or more members and deputy
group leader of the largest opposition
group to be known as deputy opposition
leader of a group with ten or more
members I call upon the leader
yes thank you chairman I'm looking to
Nick Hughes with those amendments can I
move the proposal as printed thank you
thank you do I have a seconder seconded
man intent mr. chairman
[Laughter]
this sorry chairman my polish is there
never on a Thursday do members agree
thank you that concludes the business of
this annual meeting of the council and I
apologize for not having read the script
in advance but I'll do better next time
thank you very much